what i realized as i've become more part
of the right and conservative and i i do
things with turning point or just uh
within the last couple weeks i i hosted
this prageru gala where desantis was
speaking it was at the height of the uh
don't say gay thing i'm bringing him on
stage i introduce him to my husband he
immediately says congratulations on the
kids big smile picture with us it's like
that shows the difference between
community
and collective
hello everybody and welcome to the
reuben report i am not dave rubin i have
sort of quaffed and sprayed hair i am
wearing a tailored blazer but i am not
dave rubin i am michael knowles my guest
on today's episode of the reuben report
is
dave rubin dave rubin a new york times
bestselling author and the author of the
new book
don't burn this country dave thank you
so much for coming on your show
michael thank you so much for having me
on my show and before i say anything
else
does it hurt that you have to refer to
me as new york times best-selling author
because they did not put you on the list
now your book sold like 10 times what
technically should have put you on the
list but they felt they could stick it
to you for some reason they didn't stick
it to me maybe they're going to stick it
to me with this one yeah but how does
that feel to you i mean we all know that
the new york times is complete nonsense
and bunk and propaganda and everything
else but nonetheless as someone hosting
someone else's show and having to say
that
i am very much a non-new york times
best-selling author and for for a while
we were all joking and you would say you
wear this as a badge of pride because
the new york times we all know they're
bunk the new york times best-seller list
like all the rest of their newspaper is
an editorial product there was actually
a court decision about this so they
really can just pull you off the list no
matter how many copies you sell so that
that's one side of it but on the other
side and this actually gets to what you
talk about in the book
it does matter the fact that the radical
left controls all of these institutions
will determine
where your book gets placed in the
bookstores it will determine if it goes
on classroom curricula it will determine
how it's talked about how it's reviewed
it it really matters and we're now just
talking about one small subset of just
one institution on the left this is true
of all of the left-wing institutions so
there's a lot i want to talk about in
your book but first because i'm hosting
the show this is my show today thank you
very much i want to talk about my
favorite part of the book which actually
comes in the middle
and it's you know in the book uh it's a
you know a sort of natural follow-up to
don't burn this book your your first
book and it talks about all sorts of
ideas and different parts of philosophy
libertarian philosophy conservative
philosophy but what i love is in the
middle
you don't just talk about ideas you talk
about
doing something you talk about not just
how we're going to tweak this policy how
we're going to tweak this you actually
built something you yourself you dave
rubin built something called locals
locals now affiliated with rumble which
is
which is a separate conservative or at
least non-woke institution
yeah non-woke institution that's really
all it is i wouldn't say it's
conservative or libertarian or
progressive or democrat or republican or
anything else we basically just wanted
to be a neutral platform and you know
for all the years you know knowles you
and i have been having these chats on
each other's shows regardless of who's
hosting what for a couple years now and
and even before i knew you you know i
was having all of these
talks with all of these people and we
were talking about free speech and we're
being censored on these platforms we
know about de-boosting and shadow
banning and all of these other orwellian
terms but nobody's doing anything about
it and it really started hitting me it
was like man
the cavalry ain't coming there's nobody
coming to save us we have to save
ourselves and you know it's kind of
funny now four years after having
created locals and since we've merged
with rumble and my idea with locals of
course was hey i just need a digital
home i need a place where i own my video
i own my audio i own the user data so
that if i ever want to leave locals not
that i would want to leave i created it
and by the way i think only one creator
out of our tens of thousands has ever
left and it had nothing to do with
locals
but i thought let me create this thing
and then see if other people want it too
so we really created it for me first and
then we realized oh wow we've got we've
actually got a business here so this is
this is pretty great because otherwise
just talking about the stuff and this is
an ironic position i suppose for two
guys that talk for a living
you know at some point it starts making
you crazy right if you and i just
complain about the republicans didn't do
this and the democrats did do this and
wokism in schools and gender theory and
but we don't actually start building new
institutions
at the end of the day we're gonna go
nuts and by the way that's why a lot of
the talking heads that you see over the
years they get progressively crazier
because if you're just screaming about
stuff but not changing stuff you're
going to be crazy and since uh you are
hosting my show i will say something
nice about the the fine folks at the
daily wire look you guys are doing the
same freaking thing what you guys did
with jeremy's razors as a an attack
instead of just taking instead of just
being attacked you said no we will
attack harry's they make up this
nonsense it had to do with your tweet
you guys poured i think millions of
dollars into an incredible campaign
you're now selling your own raisers
you're launching a 100 million dollar
campaign for for daily wire kids
that's very much in line with the ideas
of the book politicians are not here to
save us you either better figure out a
way to save yourself or you better find
some people
who can help you save yourself together
not not as a collective but really as a
community not as just oh i'm a cog in a
machine but as oh i have shared values
with these people let's build some
things that's why i created locals
that's why we merged with rumble that's
why we do stuff together and and that's
what people are looking for they're not
looking for us to just bicker over
marginal tax rates or or even the more
existential stuff they're not just
watching us to have the endless debate
about abortion which of course we can do
and we've done before they want answers
that that's what i'm interested in
otherwise knows we're gonna don't you
feel that like we would just yeah don't
you feel it if you just do this every
day you just talk about this stuff every
day but you don't do anything what's
gonna stop you from just being a
complete
talking head screaming lunatic and
there's plenty of those they're all on
msnbc that's right this is something
that's really refreshing about the book
but more importantly it's refreshing
about what
is happening right now what you're doing
with locals what we've done with
jeremy's razors and now dw kids we're
not going to take our kids to disney
world we're going to take them to wire
world whenever i shouldn't even say that
because you know jeremy's going to go
dump 50 million dollars into that the
minute even here's the idea
there is
this issue on the right and we're all
guilty of it on the right on the left
you can take a room of a hundred
leftists maybe they have different
interests and different points of view
you can get them on board with something
you can get them to work in concert i
mean that's what we're seeing with the
corporations and the big tech platforms
and the government and the media and the
schools they all get on the same page no
matter what their slight disagreements
might be
when you get into a room full of right
wingers you get if it's 100 right
wingers you're going to get a hundred
different opinions and they're going to
fight tooth and nail over every issue
and a lot of those debates really do
matter a lot of those debates are really
important but they paralyze you they
stop you from doing anything and so i'm
just so happy to see okay while we're
figuring out whether it's marginal tax
rates or it's life and death while we're
doing that how about we build up some
institutions that will even permit us
to have that discussion well you know
the thing is michael you know the joke
it's like if you go to a libertarian
conference you know in essence you're
just going to have you know 15 opinions
you're going to have 10 people at the
table 15 opinions on whether you should
have driver licenses or not and then no
one ever accomplishes anything right so
but there's a reason there's a
fundamental reason that does happen with
people on the right and it doesn't
happen with people on the left and it
gets to sort of what i just hinted at
the difference between
the collective and a community they love
the collective that you know we're just
pieces of the machine all of us and
we're just completely interchangeable
and actually
whether you're black or gay or lesbian
or
blind or whatever else that matters more
than whatever your
whatever remaining individual thought
you have
now on the right what you want to do is
if you believe in the individual first
that you michael knowles believe it or
not are capable of logical
thoughtful reasoned thinking you have
some sense of how you can live your life
and that the system should just exist to
allow you to flourish and then hopefully
after you've figured out some stuff for
yourself
maybe you meet a gal that you like and
you start having kids and then maybe
you'll move to a community that some of
the people there are somewhat in line
with what you believe and then you can
flourish and build businesses up that's
the bottom up approach they like the
other approach which is there's a
machine now fit into the machine and i
get why that's that's attractive to
young people that in many ways is what
we're fighting that's kind of what the
book is about we're fighting something
that is much bigger than us because it's
about the human condition people just
want to fit in and if the last two years
of covid taught us anything they will
give up almost everything that is good
and true in the name of fitting in
that's what i want to fight that's why
the word dystopia is in the subtitle
because
this is a dystopian now we are in a
futuristic movie what happens in every
futuristic movie big government
controlling speech people are afraid to
talk to each other people are locked in
their houses there's a pandemic
overreaching government it's like the
pieces are all here we just need
schwarzenegger to come in and you know
defend the three boobed woman
right that poor three boobed woman we've
got to protect her won't somebody please
think about remember they shoot her
right up close remember the guy just
yeah
yeah it's it's not you can look that up
after you finish this episode different
it's different
but i love this distinction you draw
here between the the collective and the
community because very often a lot of
talking points frankly on the right
but but just broadly
posit that there is the collective and
the individual and they just leave it at
that but of course if we're just a bunch
of atomized individuals then the minute
that we're all broken down to the
individual level the left is going to
come in and bring us all together and
collectivize us frankly in the left's
collectivizing scheme you see this in
communist revolutions you've seen this
for well over a century on the left the
first thing i do is try to split people
down break up their cultures break up
their communities break up their
families and then they can bunch them
all together and you're saying no the
individual isn't the end of that there's
actually we're human we're social
obviously we're going to come together
but what we want is a flourishing
community where we all fit where we all
have a purpose where we don't lose our
individual selves unlike what the left
is offering which is total homogeneity
and do what we say or will will
un-person you from society well knows
i'm glad that that part resonated with
you because you know as someone that is
i still think of myself as roughly new
to this side of the aisle let's say and
as you've long said i'm going to end up
the furthest right of all of us
um
you know that was an important piece for
me to take from the first book but
expand upon in this book in other words
you know the first book which was a
defense of classical liberalism really
is a defense of the individual first but
that isn't enough it you know that's one
piece and that's an important piece and
in some ways it's the most important
piece which is why i believe it's the
it's the building block it's what all as
as jordan peterson would say it's what
all western civilizations are predicated
on that the individual has sanctity and
value in and of itself right but that
really isn't enough and then and then
this is their great trick so their great
trick is okay you're a person but really
you know as we said before you're just
black or you're just gay or whatever and
it's like not it's not just that we have
to say that's not true we have to show
people why that's not true so you know
for example look as you know and you've
been to my house for dinner michael
knowles i am married to a man now that
does not uh equal the the sum totality
of who i am or who david is or anything
else just the way you and your wife your
your marriage or your heterosexuality
is not that's not the totality of you
right there's a couple other things you
got there you like cigars
i like to think of myself as a super
straight
uh but i suppose there are other aspects
of my personality sure i love this
phrase super straight this came out of
nowhere because the left that's another
thing the left does because they march
on everything sane now regular straight
people have to say that they're super
straight just to prove how straight they
are it's like i'm the he-man of straight
people
um
but
i mentioned this because what i realized
as i've become more part of the right
and conservative and i i do things with
turning point or just within the last
couple weeks i i hosted this prageru
gala where desantis was speaking it was
at the height of the uh don't say gay
thing i'm bringing him on stage i
introduce him to my husband he
immediately says congratulations on the
kids big smile picture with us it's like
that shows the difference between
community
and collective because if if the right
was a bunch of collectivists
what he in essence would want if you
were to believe what they tell you about
desantis
he would hate gay people right he would
be completely against gay people and it
wouldn't matter if i agreed with him on
everything else if i did not accept and
bow to him at every level i would be out
but what i have found is i go to these
events i go speak at liberty university
the largest evangelical school in the
united states in front of 14 000 kids
and they embrace you for that it doesn't
mean we agree on every little thing it
doesn't mean that we're gonna
all all love each other and not judge in
any way i mean you know cert you know
from a religious perspective i suppose
you should try not to judge but judgment
is part of life you know we all judge
every second of the day if someone shady
looking is walking down the street you
judge them and move the other way i mean
you racist
you prejudiced oh sorry i don't want to
interrupt no you got it you got it that
but that's that's what they do if i just
to say that someone would imply well
what do you mean they look shady you
must be thinking about their ethnicity
and it's like no a shady guy if i you
know if i saw some guy with you know
crazy facial things and tattoos
everywhere and holding a bat i don't
know i might go i gotta get on the side
street
but the point is there there is a
plurality on the right and i don't know
i mean i guess maybe this is what my
next book will be about can it hold
can the this alliance that
that i'm trying to create that i think
many of us are trying to understand the
more libertarian the ex libs the
religious
nationalists
can this thing hold i think it can if we
just turn back to those foundational
documents but it ain't going to be easy
but i'll tell you this it's a hell of a
lot better than what those other guys
are offering right and and you do bring
up this is a tricky issue i don't know
that there's been an answer yet to this
coalition can you really fit frankly i
don't know that the conservative
coalition even 50 years ago made all
that much sense you've got the religious
right
traditionalists which are similar but
not exactly the same thing you've got
the libertarians you've got sort of
warhawk
democrats they they became kind of what
the neoconservative movement of the lat
you know and you've got all these isms
and ists and that and they they all came
together during the cold war to fight
the soviet union the traditionalists
hated the uh well the economic
economic first i guess led this thing
but you had the libertarians hated the
collectivism then second in the
coalition you had the traditionalists
and the religious right they hated the
atheism and the iconoclasm of the soviet
union then you had the warhawk democrats
hated the imperial ambitions and they
all came together even though they
didn't agree on a whole lot
well now
i mean you're not papering over
differences here there are conservatives
who
hold to the traditional view of marriage
obviously who are religious who who
check all of these boxes who simply will
not agree with you on on your more
libertarian positions and then the
question is
can
can everyone work together
to stop the woke threat
without without giving up their own
views in the meantime
so
as i said i don't know that i have the
answer to that fully well i know that i
don't have the answer to that you don't
have the answer none of us do because
it's a work in progress right so we're
not there yet and maybe there is no
there there maybe it's just a project
that will just continue sort of as long
as america is to continue but what i
would say is generally speaking right
now in 2022 america and and this very
much is the purpose of the book we have
to defeat the woke thing
and and we have to give the devil is due
they've done a hell of a lot of damage
they have destroyed so many things
including imploding disney right now and
i basically despise star wars at this
point because of what they have done to
it so they've destroyed our educational
institutions our financial institutions
i mean they've really wrecked havoc over
everything we should acknowledge that so
okay there there's that
so it's that versus the rest of us the
the the groups that you just decided now
i would argue
in essence
we have to put aside some of our
differences while we build the new stuff
while we build the new internet pipes
while we build the new businesses
jeremy's razors while we build the new
entertainment companies payment
processors the whole freaking thing now
if we can really build some some good
things and of course they're all going
to be built in red states obviously um
the question is after that if we can get
to that that there there
then what do we do how do we then once
we've you know we've gotten to the
promised land so to speak now the other
issues are going to start popping up
again wait a minute you gay married
people and you catholic traditionalists
we've got a problem here or whatever
that is now we're going to have to work
through that again i think the founding
documents
give us the best path forward to that
continuing to base it on individual
rights and i i personally respect
religious liberty as long as it does not
step on my individual liberty i know
that some religious conservatives don't
love that um and there's there's reasons
for that but that's the stuff we have to
hash out that that's worthy of hashing
out because the alternative michael is
at the end of the day if we don't do
this thing they want we get running
it's over congratulations we're all in
the gulag together and then we're gonna
really have to live together in small
cells and eat gruel and it's very cold
and wet in there and you know i don't
know that i want to be in there with you
well so since you bring it up you bring
up this word sanctity you bring up sort
of these religious questions you
mention you know we've got to hash this
out cardinal manning famously said all
politics all human conflict basically is
theological at the bottom one of the
more striking points in your book
is
when when we first met each other dave
when we first became pals you were an
atheist
today you are
not exactly an atheist
no i i am a believer there is no
question about it i am willing to say
that knowles
how did it happen
look there there were a couple things
you know partly
one of the reasons i had never as an
adult i had never said i was an atheist
until about 2 000 i think it was if i
remember exactly correctly it was the
fall of 2015.
so i am now in 2022 i'm 45 years old so
you know it's about seven years ago i'm
in my late 30s and i always sort of felt
somewhat agnostic but i always loved
logic and reason i grew up reading all
of carl sagan's books so i loved sort of
i loved sort of a distant respect for
belief in a way but not like a hardcore
belief something like that um you know i
also i come from a secular jewish family
that while we did all of the holidays
and traditions which is which is
basically what kept jews around for five
thousand years um it's different in
terms of the the belief in god is a
little bit different than say than say a
catholic or we like to we like to say
secular judaism is jewish
you know emphasis on the ish yeah and by
the way our good friend dennis prager
has written many books about this that
maybe that thing just can't last that
long that it's not enough to like
seinfeld and eat bagels and all of those
things although those are worthy those
are worthy things man i made a
an everything bagel with lox the other
day miami you can get it they say it's
all in new york and jersey i know you're
a new yorker originally yes you can get
a good bagel down here in miami but
because where did the new york jews go
they've all fled now right they're all
all heading down to the free state of
florida all the sane ones now are in
florida and it's just the bananas one
still in new york uh but in any essence
i i in 2015 i started having a bunch of
well-known atheists on my show primarily
sam harris was sort of the first one
and i just sort of started going into
that world and for a long time i never
said i was an atheist but a lot of
people just kept saying dave's an
atheist because it was just by the
nature of the conversations that i was
having uh i had ion hersey ali on and
pete pagosian who wrote uh a manual for
creating atheists and michael shermer
from skeptic magazine i know you know
all these guys yeah and and so i just
sort of got
like sort of caught up in that thing but
then eventually i started saying i was
an atheist i would say a couple things
started moving me on this first off as
you know a couple years later i was on
tour with jordan peterson and we did 120
shows in 20 countries and he was not
only i had read 12 rules for life and i
had flipped through maps of meaning it's
a very intense book um but being on tour
with this guy and every night hearing a
different speech
related to the importance
of belief and that in many ways whether
you believe you are or not you are a
believer uh so i don't mean this to to
attack sam harris for example but sam
harris says you know he's not a believer
he's an atheist but it's like he does
believe that trump is the devil that's
where all of his actions over the last
couple years politically seem to come
from i don't know he might not believe
in god but he does believe in the devil
that's a great observation ah i get one
let's go on a show that's what i always
say um
that
then i heard jordan say a few things
related to belief specifically that i
really loved one of them you may have
heard this he was on uh this is a little
bit later actually so i'm jumping ahead
a bit but he was on tucker carlson's fox
nation show and he was talking about the
nature of belief and he said that when
he was in his early twenties he's he
decided to tell the truth for the sake
of telling the truth that in essence
that if you told the truth that that
would be the best outcome no matter what
doesn't mean that it would be a good
outcome because obviously you can tell
the truth and they might hang you for it
but actually it would be the best
outcome that's an incredible leap of
faith to believe in truth for truth's
sake there's no tangible reason to
believe that in many cases there's the
reverse of that because we know what
happens to truth tellers right you're
going to be lambasted and ask jesus
you're gonna there's a lot of things
that are bad that are gonna happen right
but i really love that explanation of
truth that that truth for truth's sake
is a leap of faith in and of itself
what a great kernel that is to start
with something and then you know through
the year of hearing jordan talk about
this and really also it wasn't just
at a personal level for me because i do
the politics thing that you do as well
i you know i talk about things broadly
at a societal level and it's like
it's not working without belief
once you remove god nietzsche said you
know god is dead but that's a warning to
you people that's not you know people
think oh god's dead let's do whatever
the hell we want but it's actually a
warning because it's like man that hole
is big
that hole is big and you're gonna fill
it with some other crazy [ __ ] and
congratulations now boys are girls
non-racists are racist two plus two is
five the litany of le tinx and all the
other nonsensical phrases that we have
um that's what we filled it with we we
filled it with secularism on steroids
it's not to say that secularism
and your ability to live as you wish is
not important of course it's important
and i want to live in a largely secular
society obviously but we need some
guardrails on that so i would say
you know some people's belief is purely
it's purely spiritual they they feel a a
very deep spiritual sense of belief
i wouldn't say that's the primary driver
of mine i would say it's it's a logical
it's a logical rational and almost
necessary need for belief i would say um
but i certainly feel it more uh maybe
it's a little bit i'm 45 now so this is
definitely what i suppose they call
middle age you young whipper snapper and
so maybe it's a little bit of that maybe
it's also it was one of the things that
that made me want to finally have kids
after not wanting to have kids for a
long time um
there's something going on here that's
beyond us nulls and i think i think
societies have to understand that
otherwise the the winds of of the day
will will blow over the whole thing
every time we are in the middle of it
right now now it's a settler there i
feel i feel pretty good about that
no it it you're i think you're pretty
close to it you're what you're what
you're really close to here
is
is something that so many people on the
left refuse to get to which is
humility it's just saying there's
something bigger than me maybe i don't
have all the answers maybe i need to
suppress
at least some of my interests and
desires for the truth for truth's sake
similar thing happened to me
with uh
you know i was an atheist for 10 years
and i was
pretty hardcore about it i you know i
was pretty firmly atheistic for most of
that time and
it was only an intellectual journey
it was only uh just reading and logic
and arguments that took me from
at least that's how it appeared to me at
the time to go from atheist to being
open to that question now i would say
there was a little more spiritually
going on too but it was only after all
of that that i started to have really
what you'd call religious or spiritual
feeling and as you describe dave the the
more you do it the more you do it the
the more it happens to you the more you
practice these kinds of things and and
so it this raises then a question for
the book and we're joking about what
your next book is we joke about how
you're going to end up to the right of
mussolini and and all of us are going to
say dave what are you doing where you
know you got to come further left but a
lot of times people who are on the left
who then move in more conservative
circles they say i didn't leave my party
my party left me and bill maher just
came out and said this again and
certainly that happens sometimes
but but it seems to me reading your book
something more than that has happened to
you it's not merely yes the left is
going completely insane yes they move
very very far
but you have changed too
yeah well absolutely i've changed
there's there's no doubt about that you
know people used to say oh your politics
changed so much and then i sort of had
that line you know i didn't leave the
democrats the democrats left me or i
didn't leave liberalism liberalism left
me but you know it's funny when bill
maher says that now in 2022
it's like that's what ronald reagan said
literally 45 years ago who was once a
you know a california democrat to
ultimately become the sort of standard
bearer of you know republican
conservatism so this is something dennis
prager has talked about for many years
as well and and even shapiro's talked
about it you know i got shapiro once
seven years ago on my show to admit that
in a perfect world he basically is a
classical liberal he would never want to
be described as a liberal obviously and
i'm sort of that was also a little bit
actually to fully answer your question i
also became sort of um exhausted by
explaining liberalism so it while at
some level
i still there's nothing that i wrote in
the first book that i don't believe
anymore
for me to run around to try to explain
constantly how
i am a true liberal and these lefty
whack jobs who say that they are
liberals are not liberals and i have at
this point barely any differences with
conservatives the words all become so
crazy that i started giving it up but it
also was to to get to your point
people before me have said this ronald
reagan i didn't leave the democratic
party the democratic party left me
so something was going on a long time
ago
and that does lead to a little bit of
the humility uh david horowitz is
another he's like the really famous
example of this because he was a lefty
son of marxists and communists his whole
life
reagan's reelection he says he's going
to vote for reagan he he was the
original why i left the left guy which
is a phrase now associated with me
um
but it's like these things have happened
before and it's not just that i had a
[ __ ] it's not just a political shift it
is a shift
that is more than that it is a shift in
some ways that is spiritual and and i
would say on the religion thing to link
it back to that you know who are the
people in the last two years of covet
insanity that didn't lose their minds
almost everyone on the left completely
lost their mind at every level the very
same people
who were screaming while trump was
president i'm not going to take the
vaccine i don't trust the government all
of that stuff we've all seen the videos
of all of the msnbc hosts and all of the
democrats kamala harris included i don't
trust the cdc and the who are these
people and trump should fire fouchy the
second the politics shifted and they had
their guy in office they were saying the
complete reverse and also saying it was
going to be mandated on you too
that is somewhat spiritual it is
somewhat spiritual because the the
people who stayed sane they weren't
making their decisions based on oh i
like trump i don't like biden or i don't
like biden i like trump they were making
their decisions based on the sovereignty
of their mind and their body and it's
actually quite irrelevant who was in
charge politically so the people who i
found over the last two years didn't go
bananas and by the way an awful lot of
people did go bananas and many of them
atheists
they proved something to me it that's
the proof is in the pudding so when i
meet all of these evangelicals who the
left always tells me hates me and
they're nice and warm and welcoming and
happy and come to my shows and hug me
and say nice things to me and then they
didn't go covered crazy yeah you think
that maybe has a little something to do
with the fact that they believe in
something and what they believe in is
not government i think maybe there's
something there
one of the great hoaxes during kovid was
that the crazy right-wing christians
they think they could never die from
kovid and of course the opposite was
true the reason that generally speaking
conservative christians remain sane
during covet is because we know we are
going to die we're not going to
eliminate germs and death from our
society we were looking at the numbers
we were looking at the evidence we said
you know i i think this is being over
exaggerated i think this is i actually
don't think this poses as great a threat
to me a healthy young guy as we're being
told it is i don't think the masks are
doing exactly what we were told the
masks are doing i don't i just don't
really
i have faith in the eternal things death
and taxes i have faith in my god i do
not have faith in dr fauci and and it
was on the left that you had this
neurotic fear of death this absolutely
preposterous cultish worship and
idolization of some bureaucrat in a lab
coat
it's it's ironic that the people who are
accused of fairy tales and make-believe
were were the most grounded they were
the most empirical people the whole time
well we could even connect that to
something roughly going on right now
which is that the very people who for
the last however many years have told us
how much we should hate evil
corporations right corporations have too
much power over us and they buy too much
political influence and they must be
evil and they're somehow capitalistic
that's doubly evil who do they love
right now they love disney they love the
most evil corporation in the world that
is trying i mean
desantis is literally fighting disney
tooth and nail right now to keep their
policies out of floridian's classrooms
he's the guy that was exec
elected to be executive chief executive
of the state now you may not like his
policies but that's what his job is
but the pa this and that's what i mean
about people flipping all of their
beliefs based on politics and you can't
disconnect that
from people that don't have a belief in
something else if you just believe that
on any given day whatever happens
whatever happens politically or
culturally that's reality you are going
to be freaking crazy especially in an
age of algorithms and big tech and bots
and everything else if your if your
world view
is this got a lot of retweets
that guy said the thing and he's wearing
the lab coat and the rest of it
and the fact that you know and the book
does go quite heavy into this too the
mainstream media has lied to us about
absolutely everything so now you take a
bunch of people who maybe don't have a
very strong original
say base view of the world they haven't
figured out if they believe or they
don't believe they're not sure if they
believe in individual rights or what
they really believe you take them
they're already sort of shaking now you
take
a pandemic you throw it on top of that
now they're really kind of crazy and
scared and everything else and then you
take a media that has literally lied
about everything from hunter biden to
brett kavanaugh as a racist to the
covington kids to kyle rittenhouse as a
white supremacist to very fine people on
both sides to the litany to jesse
smallette we could do this all day yeah
well
of course you're going to end up with a
population that is half insane
population that half of it is insane
right right
you you bring up your governor down
there in florida you've brought him up a
few times now dave uh so
i have to ask we're having this
wonderful religious
cultural philosophical conversation
by the way you're a great host i just
want to say really stop it by the way
get out of here you're going to make me
blush come on if i weren't so tan i'd
blush
but i i want to
i want to i want to put all that good
stuff aside for a second and talk about
rough hard
nuts and bolts politics because this is
a you know big theme of the book and
what we're talking about here what are
you going to do about it you've got this
you got a right wing right now that is
doesn't have very much holding it
together and the conservatives are
becoming more conservative and the
libertarians are becoming more
libertarian we don't have the old soviet
union to hold us together the left is
getting so much more aggressive they
barely see any distinction between
anyone on the right anyway they want to
just kill us all and salt the earth on
which we once stood
is there someone who can bring us
together in 2024 say whether that's your
governor whether that's trump whether
that's someone else in the country is
there someone who can do it or do we
need to wait for a new candidate well
first as i try to make the argument in
the book you know politics is not going
to save us here so it is the stuff
that's going to save us is what we
started talking about which is the build
new things figure out your community and
your life and all that however politics
is not nothing there is a reason that we
do this for a living and even if we want
even if in the world that you and i
michael want to live in politics should
be small enough to fit you know in a
little box that we can tuck away in our
pocket that's not what we have right now
so we have to fight for that let's say
um and and at the end of the day
the size of that thing may be a little
bit different for for the two of us
um i would say this about desantis look
it is not going to get better than him
it really isn't in an american context
of politics with a deeply corrupt media
i would say at this point an evil
corporate press
you are not going to get a better guy
than this he's 42 43 years old military
background he is fearless in fighting
the media i i've now i've had dinner
with him a few times and i've spoke to
him a couple times and i've listened
i've gone to events where he's spoken at
and i can tell you this guy
he does not want to be king he does not
want to be your ruler he he's a guy that
sort of it doesn't even sound at some
level like he wants to be president like
he really sounds like a guy that should
be
and i guess this is a little bit of the
trump thing that he should be running a
business he's like i say things i make
decisions we see what happens and then
you know i do it again he doesn't get
affected by polls um he's strong he's
picking the right fights you know he's
you know and i say all this without i
don't worship politicians i i obviously
i happen to i like and admire the guy
obviously um but i like and admire him
because of the reasons that because of
the
fact that he wants to mostly stay out of
our lives the point of the don't say gay
bill
h1557 which again has the word gay isn't
in it and they could have just as easily
called it don't say straight bill
because you're not allowed to talk about
straight sex with a second grader
obviously you morons um the point of the
bill was to keep the government out of
these things that state employees
shouldn't be discussing these things
with kids it's not more government it's
less government actually it's the
government reigning in what state
employees can do so that to me is the
type of thing that we want now we have a
great
problem i would say a good problem here
in florida which is that he's up for
reelection obviously in november he's
going to win by a landslide i think he's
well he's going to win and i hope and i
believe it will be by a landslide and
then what i hope happens from that is
that landslide then really causes the
states to to start going like dominoes
won by you know we got the yunkan win it
was pretty damn close desantis will win
by more hopefully texas stays uh red
tennessee's obviously going to stay red
you're going to be fine but then some of
the places that could go either way a
colorado indiana okay
that they're going to fully go red
and then it doesn't mean that everyone
in those red states is going to have
every perfect republican party platform
i always remind it i write about him in
the book in a different context but
everyone thinks and knows that rudy
giuliani obviously is a conservative
rudy giuliani happens to be pro-choice
but no one's doubting that he's a
conservative and that you would want
rudy giuliani on your side regardless of
the you know the bad hair dye dripping
down his head and and some of the
yelling and everything else i mean he's
a good guy you would want him on your
side he's a fighter so i want to santas
to crush here
and then i suppose after crushing here
crushing here that then he is the best
candidate for 24
the trump thing is what confuses this
would the best situation be that trump
is the bodyguard run the rallies fight
for the platform and the party in the
country and let desantis go through
that's the best situation can trump do
that does he want to do that does he
want to put his ego aside to do that i'm
not sure and the other problem with the
trump thing and i and i look forward to
interviewing him again
and i hope if you interview him that you
could ask him this directly which is
that the fear with the trump thing i
think there's two real things which is
one would the machine allow him to win
right right whatever that would be even
be possible right would it even be
possible that's number one and number
two even if you accept that the machine
would whatever i mean by that
the base of the democrats is so
depressed right now their candidate has
dementia and the backup woman is is i
think
uh
has the equivalent let's say iq of maybe
a sixth grader
she was polling at zero in her own party
everything is a mess right now inflation
gas prices they made up the war the
other thing it's all terrible
but suddenly if trump runs you can
probably get five million extra people
to show up out of the woodwork just
because they hate trump so trump really
has to acknowledge those things and
again that's not a knock on trump and i
really would ask him that to his face
what he thinks about that
but all of that being put aside i think
there's such a rich opportunity for a
truly
interesting wide tent republican party
right now but it's going to be work for
us man it really is i love your point
too
about
yeah obviously you want a good
presidential candidate you hope it could
be this guy or that guy but but even
before that
you get a big win in virginia and then
you get a big win in florida and
especially in florida desantis has done
a pretty good job
selling the political agenda of the
parental rights and education bill of
going after these corporations and so
you're seeing trickle effects of that
all throughout the rest of the country
that that's really what we've got to
focus on right now if you can turn the
country you can turn the states you're
really setting the stage for a much
larger national win now we've been
talking about michael let me let me just
say one thing real quick because your
own life is an example of this you we
had that conversation in my backyard in
l.a where we said we were going to stay
and fight the next day you announced you
were leaving and you were moving to
tennessee okay fine i tried to stay and
fight it was a fool's effort i accept
that it's all good now i'm in free
florida you're in free tennessee but the
point is
don't you feel in the year plus about a
year and a half i think that you've been
in tennessee don't you now feel and this
is the way it's supposed to be this is
federalism
that the state that you live in is
actually far more important than the
federal government especially when we
have a federal government as inept as
this one so that's all all good actually
i tell my friends who are in la i've
still got a lot of friends in la a lot
of friends in new york i have a lot of
friends in the swamp in dc and they were
complaining about the masks in the
restaurant the vaccine requirements and
kovid when will kova be over and i would
tell them
i'm sorry i don't really know what
you're talking about i know what you're
talking about because i travel and so i
have to be in dc for a night or two or
new york or wherever but in my
day-to-day life covett has been over for
a year now more than a year now and and
so i you're totally right on that it's
really important to focus on those
states hopefully that changes the
country before we go
you know the most interesting thing one
the book is very very funny the book is
represents this very interesting kind of
evolution of your thought from the first
one to the next one i hope there's going
to be another one
so beyond just predictions about the
future of the country or the future of
the conservative movement do you have
any predictions seeing
how your views have grown
from the first book to the second one do
you have any inkling any any intuition
of where you might be headed in your own
thought spiritual cultural political and
and where that next book is going to be
those you're a fine interviewer
you're a fine
fine interviewer you stop it um well i
do obviously and i think that that will
probably be
what the third book is about uh although
everything being equal if the ideas in
this here book take off we wouldn't need
a third book that would be my preference
it really would be you know we can all
talk about these things and then they
seemingly get worse year after year the
preference would be hey we built a whole
bunch of new [ __ ] it's time to move on
get the old i'll be on my boat
yeah exactly get the old book um but i
do have some thoughts on that i mean
i'll tell you one that that i've been
thinking a lot about at a very personal
level that is also related to all of
this which is so you know david and i
have been together for 13 years we've
been married for
seven and a half years something like
that we're having two kids and it was
funny because when i made this
announcement publicly
i got i would say 99 love truly and this
is one of those things where the
internet is very hard to gauge what's
going on because my phone's blowing up
texts phone calls all of the public
people that we all know everyone
basically congratulated me either
publicly or privately said wonderful
things there were two or three blue
check people on the right in the in the
more religious circles of the right that
that tweeted some i thought somewhat
nasty things and then you get just like
a whole bunch of anonymous trolls and
one of the one of the things that was
interesting about that oh you know what
i won't even say all anonymous trolls
you get a lot of anonymous people then
you get some people expressing some
legitimate religious points which i'm
happy to get into if you want and then
you get the trolls okay
i got a lot of people saying to me
i'm so sorry what that you had to deal
with this over the last week you know so
much hate in such a beautiful time
you're trying to expand your family and
all this stuff
and it was kind of funny because i'm
used to the internet game like you're
used to the internet game and if i was
to pay attention to what trolls or
anonymous people are saying all day long
get nothing done yeah yeah that would be
it i would get nothing done and i'd
probably be in a mental institution i'd
be in a padded cell just scrolling
mentions on twitter all day which
actually is where most people do their
tweeting from um
so so it was mostly love but it really
did
well wait first it was mostly love but
secondly people kept saying you see all
these people left kept saying see these
people on the right they really hate you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] pardon my french
it's my show but the reason i say it
that way is the people who purport to be
the tolerant people even in a moment
like this were being meaner in a way
than the
religious people who sometimes weren't
acting so religiously so i got no love
literally no love from anyone on the
left no mainstream gay magazine or msnbc
or whatever said oh here's this
interesting political commentator who
you know
wrote this best-selling book he's having
kids that's an interesting cultural
moment no it was endless hate from them
nothing but hate not one liberal
commentator that you and i both know
messaged me privately or anything but i
get all this love from the conservatives
and then some trolls come with it anyway
i mentioned this because it did make me
think
that as we talk about this new
alliance say on the right well i'm going
to have a family now and and what comes
with having a family is very much what's
in the book you have you're an
individual now you have a community then
you have a larger community around you
um you know will there be work that i
will have to do
uh to to to show these people
what the the value of
my life or what freedom is or what
pluralism is or something you know when
i had a ben shapiro on my show the first
time the first time i ever had him on
the show and i don't think we had met or
we had tweeted at each other maybe i
don't think we had met and he said this
thing about uh that he wouldn't bake me
a a cake for my gay wedding
and it's like i've had kosher cakes
they're dry nobody wants nobody nobody
wants that kid yeah you need you need
some butter in there or whatever they're
dry um
what i said to him was and i've said
this repeatedly to him over the years
that my personal belief is that if i
live as a decent human being on this
earth in a good relationship to the best
of my ability and i raise decent
children and try to be a good member of
the community and all of those things
which i'll do completely imperfectly as
i suspect you do imperfectly too
that over time if ben and i
interview each other and do whatever we
do for 50 years when i'm 82 and ben's 77
that he may although he maybe will never
say it maybe we'll at an individual
level have come around and go man you
know that conversation that dave and i
had 50 some odd years
ago his life had meaning it had value it
brought something to this to this world
so that's why whatever
disagreement it's not even disagreement
whatever difference you and you and i
might have theologically let's say
it doesn't matter that much to me
because i think we all also operate we
can operate in the realm of ideas and
then we can operate in the realm of
reality that is right here and i don't
think as i said before i don't think you
want to just do this one you do have to
do both but i think there's other ways
to to
to show the world what you are something
like that and i think that i think that
will be a bit of my challenge going
forward really and and by the way it's
not just me you know a guy who works
with you who i think is a fantastic
thinker spencer clavin is getting
married uh to josh in the next little
while wait spencer clavin's gay
that's why i read one one somewhere i'm
not sure josh is but spencer is and you
know you know spencer is very you know
he lives in tennessee tennessee is a
little more religious conservative let's
say than miami florida where i am here
here i am in a concert you know fairly
conservative place but it's a little
more ethnically mixed it's a little more
sort of new york republican mixed
something like that
so a guy like spencer is going to have a
real challenge in in those things but
but that's what life's about so
that alliance that we were talking about
before it's not just an idea it's not
just an alliance of ideas for me it's
actually an alliance of i'm going to
have to put my best foot forward in that
i'm gonna have to live in that thing
yeah and by the way even if it does not
work out exactly as i hope it will
and and the future is not written i know
it's better than the other thing because
i will not live i will not live on my
knees as just as a slave to a bunch of
people who think they own me because of
an immutable characteristic i just
simply won't do it
it's funny it's i guess it's not really
funny but when you mention the
announcement i not only did your twitter
blew up my twitter blew up and a lot of
people wanted me to publicly condemn you
and i said listen if i'm going to
condemn my friends i'm going to condemn
my friends privately darn it i'm not
going to condemn them publicly
if i'm going to go after shapiro or you
or whoever else and i think in part this
is because
on twitter everyone is just a just a box
right on twitter everyone yeah it now
it's it's quite clear i i've made no uh
secret of my catholicism catholic church
is clear not just about uh
homosexuality or
but surrogacy generally ivf for married
couples the it's clear you know they're
you're pretty limited to the things that
you can do in uh in the boudoir and i
think uh
well sorry but you know the irony of
that without getting too deep on this is
that you know the catholic church itself
has made fairly egregious
errors to put it lightly related to some
of those things that's actually not
that's not even me um that's just a sort
of a factual statement the point being
that we all live between a set of
beliefs and a set of realities something
like that yeah
and even in that case there's a line
from la roche foucault which i always
come back to which is uh hypocrisy is
the tribute vice pays to virtue you know
this this idea that when people screw up
but they're they're
not you know not not if you're
living as a liar or as a cynic but you
know so it's not really overt hypocrisy
but when people screw up when they sin
when they air that that is a human thing
to do and uh so there is this idea of
holding a standard that you are going to
fail to uphold a lot of the time but it
it
when i i was so curious when i when i
saw these people say you've i want you
to come out and publicly condemn your
friend and i thought why why what what
is the purpose of all of this and uh it
i can't i don't think i really have
quite an answer for that i could i have
an answer if someone's
were mealy-mouthed or didn't know what
they believed but frankly all of our
beliefs grow over time too i mean there
is a world i'm when i when i say you
could end up to the right of of genghis
khan or something i'm only half kidding
you you could end up in a position where
your views on on the nature of uh
of sex i'm not saying you're going to
like not be gay or something but we're
we're even where even your views on that
could be different and we we all
confront that i mean when i think about
my own behavior when i think about my
own life
my views have changed considerably and
so when you're talking about
a
uh a coalition
the first part of having a coalition is
you know having some loyalty to one
another i think it's some kind of you
know recognizing that your your friend
is different than the guy who's trying
to kill you and your friend and michael
it's
well it's very easy if if we want to
find enemies all day long there is no
shortage of enemies we will find them
every time we open up our phone we'll
find them every time we walk out of our
house we'll find them every time we turn
on the tv
so
you know actually i what you know i got
my twitter was so out of control those
couple days that honestly i don't i
don't think you condemned me publicly
and i appreciate it no i i i don't do
that i also thought i said wait you want
me to be you want me to stand up and be
a big strong guy by piling on to my
friend publicly you know and what what's
the point of that that makes me a big
strong guy no that makes me a coward
that makes me uh a weakling but you know
because the other piece of this is how
and and this very much is in the book
related to the big tech stuff is that
the algorithms and the way we all behave
has been so supercharged and
disregulating
for all of us so think about this let's
let's make it about another topic
altogether let's just say um you and i
were doing a show and we were debating
tequila versus burp scotch
i'm still a little unclear on the
difference between bourbon and scotch do
you want to clean that up for me real
quick we absolutely yes i mean i could
do it intellectually but it's better to
have a taste okay so let's say we did a
video and i think we've done we did this
for the game show on on your channel
once i love tequila you love scotch okay
great and every time we're together i
have tequila you have scotch now we
could do that video
and we could agree to disagree and have
a ball and be plastered by the end and
let's say that video got a million views
and nine hundred and uh nine hundred 000
people
just don't comment they just don't
comment because they're like oh i
watched it reuben likes tequila those
likes scotch zippity damn duda i'm going
you know to buy coffee
what happens now is you've got a hundred
thousand people that comment and out of
those hundred thousand people the type
of people the site i mean we know this
the psychological makeup of the people
that comment is going to be more drawn
towards the negative and then the
comments that are the most negative are
going to be the ones that get the most
likes so then if you then now a week
passes it's got a million views it's got
let's say 100 000 comments
90 000 of those comments are completely
terrible
i like tequila because i'm gay you like
scotch because you're a heterosexual
supremacist
all of these awful things and then the
average person then just the average
person happens to click on the video and
as before they even watch what we're
doing they look at the comment section
and all they see is hate all they see is
the endless hate and that i think
relates back to exactly what we're
talking about the average person that
exists on planet earth especially in the
united states of america is just trying
to make some sense of this thing and
just trying to do it in a way that is
hopefully somewhat decent and allows you
to
you know listen to some music you like
and and eat some food you like and
hopefully be with some people you love
that's it but the internet has and i
mean this regulated is the word point it
has completely skewed our ability to see
reality for what it is so my reality
again on that day to link it back was oh
i'm getting all this love my phone's
blowing up i i don't pay that much
attention to the mentions and then
suddenly a few hours go by and i see
friends texting me say i'm sorry you're
dealing with all the hate i'm going what
hate what hate it's yeah you know that's
one of those things but knowles i do
know
that while we may disagree on tequila
and scotch we do agree on frankie valley
well we do agree on frankie valli among
other things uh one of the uh all-time
greats a great way to facilitate while
you're drinking and chatting and and
actually speaking of one of our drinking
buddies uh spencer clavin he made this
point he made to me once the same point
that you're making right now which is
so much of our political ranker right
now is just trying to come to grips with
the internet is just trying to come to
grips with this explosion of technology
in the way that we can all be
manipulated with that it reminds me you
were talking about that bill in florida
the parental rights and education bill
the vast majority of people don't think
kindergarteners should be taught about
sex in history class well they don't
have history classes in alphabet class
i'm pretty sure in history class they
don't learn about history so it's okay
when they're a little older that's you
make a good point but the vast majority
of americans don't think that the chasm
between the vast majority of ordinary
people and the thin
sort of bipartisan ruling elite but it's
obviously on the left but there are some
republicans who go along with it who who
control all of those institutions it's
huge and they are inundating us with
this idea that it's somehow
controversial not to teach kids about
sex in kindergarten i i just i love your
sort of saying hold on pull yourself out
of twitter for a second you talk about
this we're running out of time so we'll
have to wrap it you have to buy the book
and just read about it yourself great
book but you you talk about
when you go on your sabbatical you go on
for 30 days you don't you don't pay
attention to anything anymore and then
i've i've hosted your shows when you've
come back you say what happened i threw
my phone in the ocean for for 30 days
that is rejuvenating that it is
important to remember that there is
there is a real society we're living in
with real people who actually generally
do kind of agree on things and do kind
of broadly have this idea that is truth
and falsehood and we kind of know it and
and not to get completely lost and
manipulated by a small handful of bad
actors with a ton of political power
that we all in the sane kind of center
to right are unifying to try to push
back against
knowles wouldn't that be a dystopia
wouldn't that be a dystopia that we all
sort of roughly
not all of us but like there's this real
majority of people that roughly
understand the mess of the gestalt of
life and that we can't quite see it
because the ai the algorithms
skynet turned on the machine wants more
clicks and it can get more clicks off
more clicks and that we're all playing
this game that none of us really
understand but we all kind of know it's
fixed and we don't know how much it
leaks out into reality but what that all
leads to and uh i will tease this it's
it's you're the guest host of my show
but one thing that i have not said
publicly before but i want to drop some
first-time info on the reuben report
my goal and i hope i can stick to this i
i want to close my twitter on january
1st of 2023.
a million followers i have wasted a lot
of my life on there but it's also been
very good for me but there is something
about the twitter game in particular
that i think is really breaking people
in a really weird way i think i've
roughly managed to stay sane in it but i
think if enough of us just say enough
you know tucker carlson right now is
banned from twitter and has been banned
from twitter for a couple weeks nobody's
talking about it the number one host in
the history of cable news is not allowed
to be on twitter because he said in
essence that men have penises and women
have vaginas
and he's not allowed to be on twitter on
top of the hunter biden laptop story and
everything else so what are we doing
we're giving energy to something that is
trying to destroy us we're feeding
the plant in little shop of horrors then
it's eating our friends and we're going
hey why are you doing that yeah i didn't
we were tweeting about it it was pretty
close yeah that was pr but i do love
that idea we say twitter is the devil
it's the worst thing ever it's
completely destroying our country hold
on i've just got to finish my tweet
tweet tweet tweet tweet three of course
you're putting your time your energy
that's actually that is a big deal dave
if you if you go off of twitter it
reminds me you talk about it in the book
of going off of
patreon i mean that's a big deal you
took a big financial hit
and then you didn't and then and then
you prospered and so i hope the same
thing can be true on twitter and for all
of us as we build a new culture build
new institutions
and we buy this book don't burn this
country surviving and thriving in our
woke dystopia dave thank you so much for
coming on the reuben report i really
appreciate it we're gonna have to have
you back sometime
knowles
i'm sending you a bottle of tequila
[Laughter]
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell